happy Trump of ursery precisely one year
ago the good Lord blessed us with a
Noahide deluge of leftist tears we will
look back on 365 days of cough FA then
we will also talk about how ed gillespie
lost two nights ago and Senate candidate
Roy Moore has been accused of dalliance
'as with teenage girls decades ago not
good very bad Republican pollster
Kristen Soltis Anderson joins us in
studio to run the numbers for 2018 am
baratheon roaming millennial come on the
panel of deplorable z-- to talk Kevin
Spacey's Stalinist purge and why
Facebook wants you to send them naked
pics why wouldn't they
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy trump / suri everyone now before
we get into all the good news and then
kristin is going to tell us all the bad
news we have to celebrate some
capitalism because consumer confidence
is at an all-time high the economy is
doing really well but in particular our
economy is doing very well because we
have another sponsor we have stamps calm
stamps calm is great we're gonna be
talking about Millennials later in the
show I am a millennial that means two
things I need instant gratification and
I don't want to pay very much for it
I am melded obviously to my desk share I
can't leave it I don't ever leave it
during the day I just scream for
Marshall to bring me things like coffee
and cafe and with stamps calm you can
get whatever you could get at the post
office literally anything you get there
you can get it from your desk so you
know why would you still go to the post
office and deal with their limited hours
when you can get postage on demand with
stamps calm so you can buy and print
official US postage for any letter or
package using your own computer and
printer unlike the post office stamps
calm never closes me you know I need at
least 15 or 16 hours of sleep a night
that severely limits the amount of time
that I could run errands mail packages
send out blank books to all of my
Democrat friends so stamps calm luckily
doesn't close you get postage whenever
you need it 24/7 it's really good
especially as a business solution it is
in the in the old days they used to have
these gigantic machines that would
always break and you could poet print
out your postage or stamp your postage
through them but they would break they
were clunky they're expensive no one
wants that this is the 21st century get
with the 21st century man right now if
you use this is the real reason you have
to support these guys they gave me the
promo code cough FA Co V Fe Fe so right
now if you use my promo code cough if a
CoV Fe Fe on this wonderful anniversary
you'll get a special offer you'll get a
four week trial that includes postage
and a digital scale it's free stuff guys
and the best thing of all is you'll get
the enjoyment of typing in a promo code
kofi Fae so go to stamps com before you
do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in you
COV Effie Effie that stamps.com
enter cough FA never go to the
post-office again that is just right you
got to give those guys some love okay
now it is the Trump reverser II everyone
happy day 365 days of cough FA is what
we're talking about how has he been
doing if you look at the Democrat press
releases or the mainstream media
reporting but I repeat myself then the
country is in smoldering ruins if you
look at reality not so much here is the
real story on the economic front
consumer confidence is that the highest
level it's been 17 years over half a
million jobs have been created in the
first three months in office furthermore
stock market rally has rallied since
Trump and it is the second biggest one
since JFK was in office those
destructive tariffs and trade wars the
Conservatives feared have not
materialized tax reform awaits a
Congressional vote so Congress
Republicans go and vote for it on
corruption Trump imposed a five-year ban
on lobbying the government by former
White House officials and a lifetime ban
on lobbying for foreign governments by
former White House officials on the
so-called social issues Trump repealed
the Obama mandate that forced states to
fund Planned Parenthood he reinstated
the Mexico City policy that protects us
taxpayers from having to fund abortions
overseas unlike his predecessor Trump
has refrained from refashioning the
White House into a giant glowing rainbow
to celebrate activist judges abuse of
the Constitution
instead quite the opposite of that he's
appointed Neel Gorsuch to the Supreme
Court a marvelous originalist justice
considered the second coming of Antonin
Scalia Scalia's old fishing buddy albeit
slightly thinner and less Italian he's
also appointed 12 other textualist
judges to the lower courts and many
others who await confirmation have that
immigration on immigration President
Trump has added more ice agents he has
expanded deportation priorities
he ended the immigrant advocacy program
at the DOJ signed an executive order
directing the Justice Department to
defund sanctuary cities and as a result
the number of illegals crossing into the
United States has dropped by at least
70% on foreign policy where we were
promised that Donald Trump would
recklessly plunge us into nuclear war
what has really happened well he got
some trade concessions out of China he's
convinced them to cooperate in wrangling
North Korea he very ably handled the
Syrian chemical attack which was a test
of American credibility and resolve and
specifically a test that Barack Obama
failed with his red line that was a pink
line and then it was an invisible line
he also oversaw the return of American
high school student otto warmbier from
North Korea which is added to that the
tension in that conflict but he did get
the student home before he died he
dropped the Moab on Isis over which
Syria just today declared a victory
victory over Isis he has approved the
Keystone in Dakota access pipelines
Barack Obama's North Korea strategy of
strategic patience is over Barack
Obama's Middle East strategy of leading
from behind it's over Donald Trump also
pulled us out of the pointless virtue
signaling Paris climate Accord that
experts say would have no effect on the
climate speaking of the environment at
the EPA 25 rules have been overturned 19
rollbacks are in progress eight are in
limbo 23 billion dollars of regulations
were slashed within the first six months
of that presidency while a net 13,000
new federal regulations have been added
annually for the past 20 years under
Donald Trump the number of net new
regulations is near zero as the New York
Times reported in May quote Trump
discards Obama legacy one rule at a time
this includes ending Barack Obama's
disastrous so-called clean power plan
which as the Heritage Foundation
explains would have resulted in higher
energy prices fewer jobs less growth and
it disproportionately hurt poor families
and it would have had you guessed it
zero environmental benefit most
importantly Donald Trump has cracked the
patina of credibility the Democrat
operatives masquerading as journalists
once enjoyed and sophisticated
Republicans those very nice Republicans
with nice glasses like I have that they
once indulged as a result nearly 2/3 of
Americans now recognize that mainstream
media outlets shill for Democrats rather
than present unbiased reporting and
Hollywood lies in rubble as the preening
moralize errs who hold their countrymen
in contempt are caught literally with
the
pants down all in all and unexpectedly
very cough fa year and if you've enjoyed
all of these improvements the protection
of your first and second amendments from
the clause of Hillary Clinton's Supreme
Court pick less government more freedom
and strength abroad thank a trump voter
I would also be remiss not to point out
another anniversary tomorrow is the
Marine Corps birthday from the halls of
Montezuma to the shores of Tripoli the
Marines have been keeping us safe for
two hundred forty-two years so thank you
very much and happy birthday now in the
news Ed Gillespie lost in Virginia last
night
the Alabama GOP nominee Roy Moore has
just been accused of trying to pick up
teenage girls forty years ago not good
and we are joined by pollster Kristen
Soltis Anderson for analysis on what the
numbers look like for Republicans in
2018 Kristen I have just been so
exuberant I've been so happy it's been a
very Co FFA year make me feel terrible
what is it looking like in 2018 oh but
I'm normally a cheerful person but if
you if you are on the right side of the
aisle there's a lot of data that
suggests the next 12 months could be
kind of ugly look Republicans have been
feeling good because many of these
special elections since Trump has been
become president have broken our way
whether it's John Asaf losing in Georgia
and on and on so Republicans had been
feeling pretty good about things but the
big test came on Tuesday night and in
Virginia you had in Ed Gillespie a
candidate who was trying to split the
difference between being a fairly mild
mannered nice you know DC forever I've
been in DC forever a nice guy trying to
as much as possible kind of embrace a
trump message a tough message on things
like immigration talking about law and
order issues you've got ms-13 that there
are you know over a thousand MSN
thirteen members in Northern Virginia
sort of talking about those issues and I
think in part because he barely won the
primary he was primary by a man named
Corey Stewart who made a big issue out
of keeping Confederate statues up now in
the exit polls in Virginia a majority of
Virginia voters who turned out said they
do actually want to keep those
Confederate statues up
nonetheless that was not their main
voting issue and so ed gillespie lost he
lost by more than what the polls suggest
a big loss it was a big loss and now
there's the question of does this have
national implications now I'm always
hesitant to say yes it does have
national implications because you know
whether it was that Georgia special
election or a statewide in Virginia
there are local dynamics there
individual candidates and their
personalities but I think the thing that
should have folks worried is that Ed
Gillespie x' numbers looked pretty
similar to what Donald Trump's numbers
look like especially in some of those
bellwether swing counties now in a state
that Trump won that may be fine that may
be perfectly enough to win but Virginia
was not a state that Trump won and so I
think for Republicans that are in places
that Donald Trump didn't win they're
gonna be facing a really big challenge
for those midterm elections well that's
the that's the question a lot of people
myself sort of included but I'll at
least acknowledge that I'm doing it out
of my defense of the Republican Party
and Donald Trump they'll say well
Virginia is a blue state these days it's
been going blue for a long time and
there was a statistic going around that
in the last five presidential
administrations the president lost
Virginia and New Jersey Governor ships
in the first year in office I don't know
how someone figured that out but that's
that's interesting statistic okay can we
just write it off and say well it's a
blue state Gillespie's not a great
candidate fine candidate and you know
being pretty good doesn't get you over
the finish line or should we be worried
that we're going to lose the house or
something like that so I think it's you
you should not think oh well this is
just a blue state going blue because of
the magnitude of the lawsuit I think the
let's be losses by two or three points
hey it's a blue state that happens you
tried your best but it's the way in
which he lost Ed Gillespie actually did
great in places like Southwest Virginia
places that Donald Trump did very well
in ed Gillespie's numbers were up
dramatically and up dramatically from
when he was on a Virginia ballot three
years ago so there are there is a Trump
coalition there are voters that have
embraced and Gillespie more now that
he's gotten closer to a message that's
Trump like but it's in Northern Virginia
and even in the suburbs
Richmond so not just that Beltway you
know these are all folks that work for
the government this is further south in
Virginia but nonetheless it's more
upscale suburbs these are the types of
places where Gillespie just got
annihilated and that's where a lot of
these swing districts are across the
country Republicans are struggling in
middle to upper-middle class suburbs
around metropolitan areas that makes the
math for the midterms very tough I come
from one of the most debated contested
congressional districts in the country
New York 18 in the Hudson Valley and
yeah they don't like Donald Trump
they're very much very hard to run on
him there they're a republican sort that
wears these glasses in this kind of
jacket and they work at hedge funds and
things like that now you wrote a book
called the selfie vote where Millennials
are leading Americans and how
Republicans can keep up I have a
question where are Millennials leading
us and how can we keep up so where
Millennials I think are leading America
is by embracing a lot of changes that
have other folks from other generations
feeling anxious so whether it's cultural
change with Millennials having sort of
more progressive views on things like
what is the definition of a family
things like smoking pot whether it's
economics with Millennials I think being
much more open to communism okay I mean
there is data that suggests that a lot
of Millennials don't actually really
know what the term socialism means they
think of Denmark they think well that's
that's fine
maybe we could have that here
technological change things that older
generations sort of balk at or think why
would we want to change X Y or Z
Millennials were very comfortable with
it so they don't go to church right they
don't know they're there just as likely
to do things like pray daily but they're
more likely to say I'm not religious I'm
I'm spiritual that sort of thing so so
there are there are a variety of things
where Millennials are just abandoning
institutions that their parents or
grandparents generation had embraced and
so that creates a tension when when
Republicans tend to do really well among
voters who are married who go to church
who are white who you know live in areas
that are not as dense population wise
and you see that Millennials are living
in areas that are denser and more
walkable and they're structuring their
families in different ways and they're
not going to church and there are very
it's a very diverse generation all of
these demographic things come together
to make it really hard for Republicans
to have a message to the millennial
generation without embracing diversity
without embracing different family
structures things like that so it's
created this tension and in the book I
try to give Republicans a way forward
that tries to preserve conservative
principles I don't think the answer is
Republicans should just become Democrat
alike because young voters don't love
the Democratic Party either Republicans
have been some ways been given a stay of
execution all along because while young
voters liked Obama they they're not fans
of the Democratic Party but so what are
things that conservatives can do that
are completely in line with our
principles that match up with some of
those values how can we use technology
to make government run more efficiently
make it smaller make it do the few
things that it's supposed to do really
well so it can stop trying to do all of
the other things that shouldn't be doing
stuff like that and I think that there
are a lot of opportunities that
Republicans have missed over the years
that it just it frustrates me because
now we have the oldest Millennials are
in their mid 30s it's too late to win
them back the data that scares me
nowadays is not seeing Republicans lose
voters 18 to 29 because Republicans have
been losing that age group for a decade
or more it's now that we're losing
voters in their 30s those Millennials
are getting older some of them are
getting married they're buying homes
they're paying taxes but they're not
becoming Republicans and that should
really concern the right well this room
what you said reminds me of the title of
your book the selfie generation because
there you hear this all the time people
say well I'm spiritual but not religious
which to me means I'm I don't care what
God wants but I'm very interested in
myself so I do like the idea of me you
know and that is depressing but
obviously there's a certain narcissism
that typifies the generation you might
notice that I talk into a camera for a
living every day the group that gives me
hope is the next generation Gen Z from
some of the studies that come out from
them it seems they go to church more
they're a little bit more conservative
is there cause for hope
I think there are some areas where you
find Gen Z folks who's embracing things
like tough views on immigration you know
being being pretty being further to the
right then there their millennial older
brothers and sisters aren't we shouldn't
just let everyone come in and blow up
our cities or something well they're
either there are visible views where you
know Republican teenagers have pretty
conservative views there are issues
however like gender identity climate
change where they trend even more
progressive than their millennial older
brothers and sisters um but I think for
Gen Z their views have not been cemented
for the Millennials we either came of
age right before or during the Obama
presidency and so for a whole variety of
reasons that has started to cement their
views as being a little further to the
left but for Gen Z that stuff is much
it's malleable if you think of it like
cement when you first pour concrete it's
it's malleable you can still write
things and I think that's where Gen Z is
now and if Republicans and conservatives
make an effort to actually say here's
why markets are good here's why our
values are good those are arguments that
were never made to Millennials but
there's still time well what about that
immigration argument if they're to the
right on immigration they're to the
right of what most Republicans were on
immigration even ten years ago does that
mean that we need to issue Donald Trump
and say this isn't what conservatism is
or do we have to take a little bit of
the Trump movement in the Trump election
and say yeah maybe we should speak more
bluntly about issues of legal and
illegal immigration national security
even possibly tax tax regimes and free
trade well I think the other thing you
have to keep in mind though is the
diversity of these generations so if you
look at the baby boomer generation I
think three out of four are white
non-hispanic and as you get further and
further down into the generations for
Millennials think we're about 56% white
non-hispanic for Gen Z it's about half
so it's the increasing diversity of
America is showing up most prominently
in these younger generations so the
question is how do you have a message
that says it's important to have a
secure border then it shouldn't be
considered wrong to say that that
doesn't sound like we
want America don't like everybody who
looks yeah you know you you've got to
find a way to have the argument for your
policy that does not sound like you
don't want America's changing diversity
to happen that's a hard argument for me
to make because these days you know I
guess I'd be okay in that America but
during the heat of the summer I would be
booted right across I get very swarthy
that Sicilian skin starts glowing out
okay Kristen thank you so much for being
here I really appreciate Kristen Soltis
Anderson and check out the book the
selfie vote where Millennials are
leading America and how Republicans can
keep up we better keep up because we
need to win elections and keep the cafe
coming Thank You Kristen okay we have
got to bring on our panel so before we
bring on that panel we have to remind
you about the conversation be sure to
tune in to watch our next episode of the
conversation Tuesday November 14th at 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring
little ol me little ol swarthy me the
conversation will stream live on a daily
wire website Facebook page and YouTube
channel and it will be free for everyone
to watch we are very generous
conservatives give generously to charity
but only subscribers can ask questions
because we're capitalists too I'm trying
to teach you lessons as we do this
subscribe today to ask me all of the
important questions and join the
conversation
now I you want to see Roman millennial
you want to see a Marathi
but I'm sorry to tell you if you don't
go to Delhi wire.com you can't do it so
thank you to everyone who currently
subscribes you help us keep the lights
on to those who haven't go to daily wire
calm right now
what do you get I know come on this is a
monetary exchange you get me you get the
under Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show blah blah blah blah blah
here it is as the one on the one-year
anniversary do not be drowning do not
allow yourself to drown in the deluge of
leftist tears get the tumblr you can
have that you can put them in here
however you want hot or cold always
salty and delicious they're really
really good go to daily wire.com right
now we'll be right back
[Music]
okay so in the news right now by one
welcome the panel by the way roaming
millennial thank you for being here Jo
just roaming we lost amber this is like
our second date now this is and by the
way good timing on the news cycle
because I think both of these stories
are about sex that's not going to get
Harvey Weinstein for that the first one
is Kevin Spacey they are editing Kevin
Spacey out of all the money in the world
here is Kevin Spacey for a reaction any
pugilist worth his salt knows when
someone's on the ropes that's when you
throw a combination to the gut and a
left hook to the jaw
you're gonna kill these with only as
strong as his heel every kitten grows up
to be a cat they seem so harmless at
first small quiet lapping up their
saucer of milk but once their claws get
long enough they draw blood sometimes
from the hand that feeds them that last
one is too real I sure we should have
played that one roaming is this a
stalinist purchase Spacey or is it just
capitalism at work you know what I was
actually wondering that exactly about
Stalin as well when I heard about I
think it's Ridley Scott the director
who's editing Spacey out of his movie
and you know what I okay to be honest I
actually really like Kevin Spacey as an
actor I really enjoy his performance in
house of cards he's mutant I think he's
really good at almost anything he's in
but this does make sense I mean if you
have this huge movie what is it I think
that the budget was about 40 million I
read you have this huge movie that's
going to be promoted and it's gonna be
launching at the same time one of the
main actors this is embroiled in this
awful sex scandal harassment allegation
thing it does make sense to try to
distance yourself from it now he's going
a step further not only are they
excluding Kevin Spacey from the
promotional events they're actually just
editing him out entirely and apparently
this wasn't the studio's choice this was
the directors choice specifically and I
think it is smart for business even if
it means they're gonna have to spend
some money invest a little bit more
upfront to do some reshoots but I think
it also sends a more positive message
for than what we're used to seeing in
Hollywood I mean if we look at people
like Roman Polanski Woody Allen
Chris Brown from the music side we're so
used to Hollywood kind of turning a
blind eye when these allegations are
made against people and just kind of for
acting like a never happen but at least
I think maybe now because there's so
much attention around the issue we're
actually seeing people face consequences
from it and I do want to say that I
think this is different than just one
person making an allegation against
someone that being unsubstantiated with
Kevin Spacey and people like Harvey
Weinstein we're actually seeing like
documented instances many many years and
I don't see what what immediate gain a
lot of these people would have from
launching these allegations was again
you know I'm for innocent until proven
guilty but this is something where we
have to kind of look at everything
contextually to figure out what actually
is happening and and when you're talking
about a 40 million dollar film which
when you factor in promotion it could be
70 million dollars something like that
it the thing that's really crazy about
this is for people who've never been on
a film set or been in the film industry
there there is 7 weeks right now there's
7 weeks until the release of this movie
they want to read they've recast they
want to reshoot they want to re-edit
this movie it that is insane I don't
know that it's possible that you know I
did an indie movie last year it just
started screening next week but there is
and you know for for big studio films
the 7-day told it could take at least
seven months a year to do this in seven
weeks I'm skeptical that they'll do it
but clearly they're they're worried
about their the money they're risking
from so I get their capitalists point of
view they don't want to lose all that
money nobody goes to the movies now
anyway
from the viewer though from the person
who is enjoying the artwork or reading
the book or seeing the movie should we
punish artists for their personal lives
that's something that I've thought about
as well and to me you know there's a
difference between saying oh you know
Lady Gaga she supported Hillary Katy
Perry she also supported Hillary but I
could still enjoy their music there's a
difference between saying I'm gonna let
this artist have whatever political
views they want you know and accept that
they're not gonna agree with me on
everything they might even say some
kooky stuff that's fine there's a
difference between that and saying I'm
going to continue to financially
supporting someone who is a known sexual
predator hmm I do think it makes sense
to make that distinction and I'm not
someone who's going to boycott someone
just because they have different
political views
I do or just because they have like a
personal lifestyle that maybe I don't
agree with but now we're talking about
like actual crimes that be that are
being alleged against him and I think
that is something we need to
differentiate between like oh you know
they're just I just don't like their
opinions they're from what I'm going to
boycott them like no that's not what
we're talking about that's true and I
guess if we're not gonna financially
support those predators I guess Marshall
today will be your last day there is a I
know it's sad but roaming made the
decision there's this book that Andrew
Clavin and I were reading a few months
ago called darkness at noon I forget the
name of the writer he's an ex communist
wrote a book about it's a novel about
communists basically in a Stalinist
purge and it's a it's interesting on a
sort of meta literary level because the
author of that book I believe was
accused of rape he was apparently just a
dirty rotten horrible guy and yet the
the artwork that he produced is very
good and I'm glad that I read the book
so it that is a difficult balance I I
personally don't really care how awful
the artists are I think the art stands
on its own but fair enough we shouldn't
I guess I guess while Marshalls still
here we shouldn't keep filing his
paycheck so from speaking of sex
Facebook wants you to send them nude
photos over the internet so that they
can prevent your nude photos from going
on the Internet
not sure if you saw that story this is a
statement from Facebook quote as part of
our continued efforts to better detect
and remove content that violates our
community standards we're using image
matching technology to prevent the
non-consensual intimate images from
being shared on Facebook and obviously I
am furious that I didn't think of this
first the Michael Noel's show anti nude
photo nude photo collection program
would have it's a stroke of genius
doesn't happen to everybody only those
geniuses like Mark Zuckerberg can think
of it to take their point seriously
revenge porn is a serious issue it is a
terrible thing that happens will people
will girls who send naked photos will
they use this program because they trust
Facebook more than their ex boyfriends
I think a lot of people will actually
use this program I'm someone I don't
actually use Facebook a small Facebook
I think ninth grade I deactivated it
tried to make a new one when my channel
was starting everything was different
and confused me got frustrated and gave
up immediately so I'm still not on
Facebook but a lot of people do really
trust Facebook and I think for I mean
this we've seen this happen to
celebrities all the time even I mean
this happens very calmly I think high
school college students especially I it
wasn't a thing that you know exes would
feel the need to be I guess vengeful and
to try to hurt people I just it's a bad
situation it's weird that this is now a
thing in our society I'm not someone who
would think like oh yeah better just
upload my new facebook photos to
Facebook so that the nude photos I've
said to other people can somehow be
edited out of the Internet I'm like
hopefully that's just never a situation
I will find myself in where that thought
logic makes sense but I think a lot of
people will actually do this if they are
concerned which I can see a lot of
people unfortunately nowadays being
concerned about what I wonder is if my
personal profile is already a very
tasteless nude photo will they just
automatically use that when people
upload revenge porn I don't know that
you bring up that question why on earth
in this age of hacking and of scummy
boyfriend's and a big brother technology
why on earth would a girl sends her
boyfriend or some other guy a nude photo
not that I am complaining per se but
like what that seems like the most
foolish thing in the world I mean pretty
much all of our devices are synced with
you know the cloud or something some
sort of thing that keeps not only you
know a copy of the photo on your hard
drive but also an electronic copy in
your account so just it doesn't seem
like a very good idea to me but I know
with a lot of the celebrities that this
happened to it's because they're
involved in like long long-distance
relationships still still not a very
safe and secure thing and I mean we can
talk about how it's not the best move to
make but I mean a lot of the stories
I've seen have it's happened to
high-school students who are not making
good decisions in the first place really
the emphasis of the blame should be on
the person who either hacked it or
leaked it I think it's a huge invasion
of privacy the person that happens to my
advice to everyone is to do what I do i
do Polaroid and then FedEx
overnight it's more expensive that's the
way to do it open I mean you know oil
paintings happy - yeah yeah you know
there are these pizzas really great
artists on Twitter and she keeps
painting the these photo or these
paintings from my photos you know and so
I tweeted something like paint me like
one of your french girls but I think
that was too far nobody on Twitter wants
anything to do with that alas alas alas
Romi thank you for being here we have to
move on to the mailbag always great to
see you and I will I will see you soon
now it is time for the mailbag from Pete
I am slash was a lapsed Catholic that
has attempted to return to the
sacraments upon learning that my wife is
pregnant yet I can't help but feel
dishonest with myself as I still am
heavily lacking in faith
I've been agnostic pretty much since my
confirmation I was too and nearly chose
Thomas as my confirmation name for that
reason that's exactly why I did exactly
that I want to return to the faith so my
child has the same chance at it than I
have had but I can't manage having faith
myself what advice can you give this
heretic and to any others out there I
don't doubt your heresy i I don't I
don't mean to question your apostasy but
even asking that question even having
that impulse when you think about your
future child and your pregnant wife to
me is evidence of the kernels of faith I
don't think you'd ask that question if
you didn't have it this is a difficult
question Andrew Clavin did a great video
now eight years ago at pj media called
how to find God in 60 days
because he was an atheist and he is now
a Christian wrote a great book about
that called the great good thing and his
advice is to just pretend like God
exists for 60 days pray to Him
behave like it's all true you know try
to follow God's will and then you will
and then you'll believe in him I was and
basically an agnostic atheist type from
my confirmation to my I don't know 21
years old 22 years old and I was then
intellectually convinced that God exists
by some of the arguments for God st.
Anselm and Thomas Aquinas and the
ontological in the cosmological
and so I was perfectly intellectually
convinced that God exists I don't think
there's really any good argument against
God and there are many good arguments
for the existence of God but I couldn't
bring myself to faith I couldn't bring
myself to praying to a person to a man
and that came later I don't know how it
happened I read more I followed that
intellectual journey and until the
numinous experience the religious
experience happened I would recommend
behaving as though it is true because
we'll get to this a little later another
question touches on this because there
are so many forces in this society
telling you that if you believe in God
or specifically in the Catholic Church
the the most maligned of any of those
institutions if you believe in God and
that version of Christianity then you're
stupid you're ignorant you're you're
uneducated you're you engage in wishful
thinking you are afraid of the dark and
afraid of death and you don't understand
evolutionary psychology and bla bla bla
bla bla all nonsense the as Antonin
Scalia said to New York Magazine once
many more intelligent people than you or
I have believed in the devil and it
seems to me that the weight of intellect
the weight of history and philosophy and
theology is with Christianity and with
specifically I'm a Catholic so I would
say don't be discouraged by what the
culture is telling you because you know
it's it's right there in the book pal
the culture is gonna try to tell you
that it none of its true and that you'd
be a dummy for believing it so good luck
and congratulations on your childhood
hope all grow as well
from Joseph which of the seven deadly
sins do you think is the most prevalent
in modern society yes all of them I
guess they've always all been around the
the most prevalent seems to me pride
seems to me superbia pride or humor who
hubris we were just talking to Christian
who wrote about the selfie generation
and you know the trouble with that when
it's the most prevalent obviously we're
all taking selfies all the time and I'm
speaking into a camera for hours at a
clip and you know
there isn't a lot of real friendship a
real conversation that occurs but also
it's where all of the other vices and
and sins come from so you know there is
lust gluttony greed sloth wrath Envy but
they all come from pride and it's a
pride that that I was just discussing
with that previous question it's a pride
that God doesn't exist I'm I'm the
greatest thing there is out there it's a
pride that I can do whatever I want
I'm not transcending any moral order
it's a pride that I can have sex with
whomever I want and relationships be
damned and people who love me be damned
it's a pride that I can take whatever I
want from someone else and it doesn't
really matter because there's no judge
and there's no judgment there's no good
and there's no bad but thinking makes it
so on and on and on it's it's a pride
even in sloth it's a pride that well it
all doesn't matter we're born in a
random chance and we're all gonna turn
to worm food so who cares if I get up
and do my job today or get up and do any
work or be productive it is so it
infects everything so I'd be wary of
that you know pride is a occupational
hazard if not a prerequisite of show
business and politics so we all have to
all have to be careful of that but that
that is that's the one that the devil
likes best
from James dear blank book millionaire I
wish but you know it's still pretty good
I'm not complaining Australia is still
having its same-sex marriage debate and
I am voting no to changing the legal
definition of marriage it is my view
that voting YES would be ignorant of the
history of marriage between a man and a
woman and ignorant of the fact that it
is an institution of forwarding
procreation makes sense to me pal does
this position of not wanting to give
same-sex couples the legal recognition
of marriage conflict with a libertarian
view of government no it doesn't but
people say this a lot libertarians who
have a very myopic view of politics but
I suppose that's an occupational hazard
of libertarianism
it isn't at all it isn't a matter of
rights it isn't a matter of the
government the left has done a great job
at framing the issue of redefining
marriage as one of Rights this person
has this right to marry a person that he
loves but this person doesn't have this
right to marry a person that he loves
but that's not where the debate starts
it isn't about the rights the premise of
both of those questions is that marriage
has a meaning that allows for a same-sex
monogamous Union but the question we
have to debate is what is marriage if
and furthermore what are men and what
are women if men and women are basically
the same and there aren't really any
differences between them then the left's
argument on same-sex marriage makes
perfect sense if men and women are
different if they're complementary
rather than indiscernible from one
another then they're that opens up a big
question now there is a reason that for
all of history marriage has been between
a man and women if not if not just one
woman for the promotion of our history
it's been between a man and one woman
but we also can look at marriage in
today's day and age what does it mean
what do men mean what do women mean what
what is the purpose of procreation is
the per is it to bring a child into the
world or is it so that the child can
make us feel good about ourselves and
the arguments against redefining
marriage seem to me strong and have the
weight of history to them there are some
arguments for redefining marriage but
those aren't them and there's there's
absolutely nothing that contradicts a
libertarian view of government or
conservative view of government or a
Christian view of government or
what-have-you
about not deciding to redefine radically
and fundamentally the basic institution
at the West we should engage in that
debate on a much more serious and
sophisticated level which is what is
marriage what are men and how do we deal
with a society in which traditional
marriage has broken down entirely and so
why not admit monogamous same-sex
couples who might raise children better
who might live a much more productive
life that's where the debate should be
it shouldn't be on some frivolous matter
of Rights from Gregory
hello mr. Knowles please note my name is
Joe pert I just called you Gregory it
may show my dad's name above but that is
false well I don't want to spread false
it I am a Catholic in a junior in a
liberal high school
P physics were building egg drop devices
in my group I suggested the idea of just
gluing a small cross on the egg and
dropping it unprotected this of course
was a joke but more recently I've been
wondering what in fact would happen if I
did this if I dropped an egg with just
the cross if with complete faith for the
purpose of converting the class
I dropped the egg with only a cross what
would occur I know that all things are
possible through Christ but I can't
grapple with the idea that the egg would
drop and not break in Christ Joe / yeah
good man because in the Last Temptation
of Christ I'll just read you the passage
when when the Antichrist takes Christ
down to the wilderness and he brought
him to Jerusalem and set him on a
pinnacle of the temple and said unto him
if thou be the Son of God cast thyself
down from hence for it is written he
shall give his angels charge over thee
to keep thee and in their hands they
shall bear thee up lest at any time thou
dash thy foot against a stone but what
did Jesus say Jesus answering said unto
Him it is said thou shalt not tempt the
LORD thy God it is not up to you to show
off God like a magic trick that you have
power over you don't have power over you
only but only by grace are you are you
saved by the grace of Jesus so if even
Jesus would not drop himself down to
test God and He is God I don't think you
should either because that egg is gonna
end up everywhere from Brandon dear
Michael I am the son of a Cuban
immigrant and I'm currently attending a
university where I have often heard a
romanticized view of the state of Cuba
perpetuated by students and faculty
alike
oh you mean anywhere in America yeah
that's probably where you were this
infuriates me because so many of my
family members who's still in Cuba tell
us of the plight in which the Cuban
people truly live how would you
recommend I deal with these situations
when they arise do I attempt to
re-educate these Burney loving
ignoramuses or just ignore them entirely
thanks Brandon a good question I noticed
this too when I went down to Cuba I
noticed that people don't worry a gov
ora shirts down there like all of the
idiot the white liberals where in
America who are completely ignorant of
that slave island what you should do is
give your testimony just
you have and for this might be the one
place that I'll abide that the idea of
white privilege but it is a white
privilege it's at least an American
privilege that we live in such luxury
and freedom that we can become very
lofty in our minds and say well who
cares if communism doesn't work in
practice does it work in theory yeah I
know those Cuban people have been slaves
for half of a century and they've been
killed and tortured and starve to death
but you know you know look it's
obviously was for a good purpose the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
guys so I would engage with it all the
time you have a unique perspective and
voice and people should hear from the
horse's mouth what that horrific
ideology and the horrific regime are
really like from Jordan hey Knowles my
name is Jordan since out of you Ben and
Andrew I hear you're popular with the
ladies who'd you hear that from
PS heard that from Andrew okay fair
enough it's not true yes yeah totally
fake news that's cuz I went to college
with Drew's son Spencer and maybe he
said maybe he's telling tales out of
school I'm a cashier and I work with a
girl named Samantha to be honest she's
way out of my league and more mature
than me give yourself a little credit
man we're about the same age sometimes
we make eye contact and maybe I get a
smile from her without doing anything
I'm not really experienced with asking a
girl out I'm afraid of rejection like
most what's the best way to get your
foot through the door and stay out of
the dreaded friend zone also love to
hear some inspiring love experiences you
may have had that can help and I'm not
giving you any of those man that's for
that's gonna be for my sequel romance
novel to the blanket book thank you
Michael Knowles aka
love dr. Marshall I want you to only
call me that for me dr. love baby so
I've gotten this question a few times
and so I'll give some variation on that
because I don't I don't know that I've
given a complete answer on young men
trying to find love and a swipe right
culture I have had a girlfriend for
longer than the tinder existed so I'm
really unfamiliar with that but the best
advice I'll give you which everyone will
probably also give you is to be
confident beacon a ton of really ugly
dudes
have beautiful girlfriends and wives
because they are confident Henry
Kissinger I believe said that powers the
greatest aphrodisiac so be confident be
confident yourself it isn't the end of
the world if this girl doesn't go out
with you but it would be fun to go out
with you so you know make it playful
make it a fun thing if it becomes a
creepy or desperate thing then she's not
gonna want to do it you wouldn't want to
do it either it also helps in
conversation if you like women it helps
if you actually like these people and
you're not just trying to get in their
pants or something so if you if it's
true in conversation generally if you
have a conversation with someone and you
are interested in what they're saying it
will be a better conversation and you
both will enjoy it more and you might
even get something out of it you might
learn something or or be entertained or
what have you if you're not if it's just
a technique like you read one of those
pick up books and you say hey honey and
you look like Mike the situation from
the Jersey Shore then you're gonna be a
slick creep and she won't want to go out
with you just be confident be interested
in her and keep it fun the purpose of
dating is that it's very very fun and
ultimately it leads to things that are
probably less fun and more duty-bound
like marriage and raising children and
you know being a pillar of society but
the early part the dating is extremely
fun so don't let it get you down I had a
teacher in high school who is a biology
teacher and he would say don't think of
this - oh no I'm sorry this is my
history teacher a great history teacher
and he would say don't think of this
test as an opportunity to be penalised
as an opportunity to fail out of class
or something a test and exam is an
opportunity to get points and so that
same thing with asking a girl out it's
an opportunity to go on a fun date and
you know see what happens from there but
it isn't something to dread or feel
nervous about or rejection and if you
get rejected so what that you know that
that just goes with the territory and
you try again next time I hope that
helps from the doctor of love we got to
rename the show that's real good
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
NOLA the doctor of love and we will be
back this is the end for for this week
you can survive the Clavin this weekend
by listening to another Kingdom Andrew
Clavin is another Kingdom it is the tale
of a 30-year old Hollywood schlub who
walks through
portal into another world with monsters
and ogres and a dead bloody woman at his
feet in the dagger in his hand
it's got like 500 plus reviews on iTunes
people seem to really like it for some
reason or another so please go if you
subscribe and leave a review I'll really
help us out and I think you'll enjoy it
as well as Hollywood lies in ruins
then tune in for the conversation next
Tuesday but I'll see you Monday first
I'm Michael nolza Mike no show see you
next week
[Music]
Michael Knowles show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jesuit all Vera and our
Associate Producer is Bailey Lynn the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017